[Musique]
voilà le nombre a déjà noué
ça c'est une certitude et à quelqu'un va
pas gagner sinon en enlevant que j'aime
bien en ce moment c'est rien à voir les
lettres ou alonso sur renault
voilà
oui moi je reviens au stadium est de
l'australie pim majorettes d'australie
et a dit qu'elle sait pas encore s est
passé à l'arrêt tout elle continue bon
alors qu'on était ensemble comment
j'étais avec l'olympique de marseille
mme aminatou dans l'écurie en tant que
marché les lire il ya que l'olympique de
marseille voilà mais c'est comme ça et
puis on a les toiles imprimées c'est
normal est ce que c'est et pierre ménès
qu'apparente de supporter paris c'est ça
qu'il faut se dire voilà ça sachant que
je suis à peu près 500 me sur 7 par jour
déjà en quatre jours je prends suis fait
puisque lutte donc voilà et toi c'est
mérité après une certaine gêne mais on
s'en fout il s'est pas lassé des rejets
de plus deux mais que lui en quatre
jours perdante
voilà je les couilles et